it shows lasted so much longer than they
originally predicted yeah always I think
you know I think there's been a return
to to what works in the show the the in
the last couple of years we return to
what you know angels and demons and the
brothers story in a way that was
reminiscent of the early days of the
show I think and I think it's had a
really good impact a wonderful impact in
the show I mean once you get at the end
of a five-year arc with Ricky's concept
it's very very difficult to steer that
around an exerted an amazing job to to
actually just keep the show going to try
to get it to be there continuing with
something there's a very finite ending
really and takes a while to steer that
ship around and then to have Jeremy come
in and revert it so it's almost like a
version of its original its original
piece I just think it's absolutely
brilliant so clever and I think they've
been very protective of what it is that
we love about the show we all love about
the show
they've been very yeah you can tell
something with a lot of care a lot of
passion not it's not just our how do we
get through another five episodes it's
what do we really want to say here and
that's why it's so much fun to do and
it's very fun to find out what happens
as opposed to by the gues play with it
you're still watching it absolutely want
to say there's a lot of other shows that
are coming out what role is supernatural
played and and this or a ripple effect
in the genre I have no idea
I mean what do you think is the role in
the general well I think from a business
perspective like looking at the show and
seeing the longevity and seeing that the
fans around certainly I mean um tonight
the fans are amazing on the show fans
are absolute extraordinary on the show
as they were for Firefly as they were
for battle stein and you know Breaking
Bad and the l-word and anything that was
a quality television yeah Sopranos it's
different different types of genres and
different types of expression of fandom
but I mean ours are a very vocal very
collective unit it is kind of fantastic
but but still the bed of the TV is that
more fans are on the bed of the fans
initially but there's a lot of things
showing up for Supernatural so maybe a
baby knows maybe an answer to your
question was why did they do the
original Battlestar Galactica and that's
because there were a huge amount of fans
of Star Wars right and why did the
original Battlestar Galactica not have a
Hathaway perhaps certainly not
critically away the second matter fact I
feel good because there's ways of
you know ways of creating things if you
create something with passion and heart
it can be infectious as long as you
think that I have the luck of being able
to get it on there I keep it on there
get people to see the yes you get to is
when something's done for many know that
I'm saying any of the things that I
mentioned have ever been done from
cynicism but but if something is done
with a slightly cynical age it doesn't
tend to stick with bands very well and I
think the marketing and the business
sides of television I'm very aware that
you can't comment people into watching
something they love it or they don't I
think our position I think that the best
the best props you can get Jeremy and
all the great writers on the show is
that they care enough about the show to
protect the show too you know and still
they'll try the you know we would never
the French mistake without without you
know giving it a go with something
strategy I mean they're a stand and
actually done the defense asked them
some that not as good but our audience
has always been very forgiving as long
as the story propels forward as long as
we're putting as much passionate heart
into this possible tell you I work with
you know three other principals and
hundreds about the people who on a daily
basis go to try to make the absolute
very best television that they can make
it's not a cynical or a tongue-in-cheek
as much fun as we have it's not a
tongue-in-cheek exercise it's an
exercise in love and kindness and
consideration for fans and and for each
other I mean it's an incredibly
supportive group there's no nicer place
to go what there's no nicer place and
I've worked on some amazing sets and
later
it's special and our Warner's knows
especially I know the CW nosy special I
know the fans know it's special and a
comic-con knows its mission
I know it's special and as you can't
manufacture it it is but it's a right
you know it's alright it's alright and
come with us on the ride we haven't let
you down so far right true that's the
way to look at it you know the minutiae
who wears what hat how long do they wear
it for how big is the hat it's not
really very important girl the guy girl
the guy with glasses
you tell you that's
you